mariana is with us
in santa clara clarida california hi
mariana how are you
hi getting yourself better than i
deserve how can we help
so um my husband and i started your
program uh
uh january and we we are on baby step
two um we started off with 86 000 and
then we're down
to 24 000. my my question is
uh we did have a broken lease so we
moved out of our apartment
in march when the quarantine started and
they
they shut down the office and everything
so what we did is we turned in the keys
um we we did a written note signed off
on it
and then i emailed them and also kept
trying to call until i finally get
a hold of them and they said that they
would get back to me with the closing
statement
um that they would they were processing
everything
and so i finally got the closing
statement
they gave it to me uh last week and they
said
they said uh we were still living there
up until october
so they're charging us all those months
and
if we don't pay within 30 days we'll
send it to collections so my question is
do we wait until we're done with baby
step
two and three and then and then attach
that because we want we wouldn't have
uh the full amount for for within 30
days obviously
okay so was the lease
up and you gave them 30 days notice or
you just walked out on the lease and
sent them an email
well we did give him a notice i know but
did your lease allow for that were you
on a month to month
rental if you have a 12 month lease and
you just walk out in the middle of it
you can't cancel that with an email
yeah that's what they were seeing it
yeah that's right obviously it's broken
lease
so so that's why i mean i know we kind
of
we did screw ourselves over because we
were trying to as much as we're trying
to have a broken lease fee
and that month and we were going wanted
to pay that but now they're charging us
everything which i know they have so the
lease limit the lease has a
fee written into it that you can pay and
break the lease in the written lease
yes how much is that fee yes it had it
was
one month one monthly seventeen hundred
dollars okay
and you sen and you have copies of the
emails that you sent them
yes then you're not paying through
october
because you let them know that you are
breaking the lease and paying the lease
cancellation fee correct
yes okay that's all you pay then
so um they're trying to charge you from
march to october
but you were gone you were gone you were
out of the property
yes you have any proof you have any
proof of that
i mean i i don't know what other proof
than just not being there
well where were the keys mariano where
did you turn the keys into
into the dropbox because the office was
closed when quarantine started
so in the dropbox we put a note with it
fine and they're saying they got none of
that
they're saying they don't have the keys
that's also in the closing statement
the keys for the fees for the keys they
said we
left nothing okay um and so the
difference here
is ten thousand dollars right
yeah you need a lawyer
okay because it sounds like it sounds
like these people shut down
and we're not doing business and you
half but
handled this so part of you you brought
this onto yourself
but it sounds like you have a valid case
for you have canceled the lease you can
prove the lease was canceled
uh you've got the problem was is that
they weren't working
and so they didn't even come check the
dropbox and when they did whoever
checked it didn't have two brain cells
to rub together and didn't catalog the
keys
so because i believe you that you
dropped them yeah and very honestly
the other thing is if you canceled your
utilities you may be able to use that
for proof you moved out that is true and
the new principal address that you
established as your primary
yeah but yeah that's true yeah but the
big thing is the
the cancellation email taking advantage
of the lease cancellation clause for
1700
that should be the beginning and the end
of this yeah regardless of the keys
and you were out of the property and so
that how how the heck they know if
you're out of the property they were
close
they weren't even open yeah they weren't
doing anything so eight months
yeah you need a lawyer you do you cause
you're not gonna pay
otherwise you're gonna pay ten thousand
dollars so you're gonna pay a lawyer
five hundred a thousand bucks to work
this out yeah or you're gonna end up
paying this ten thousand dollars that
you legitimately don't oh
it sounds like with what you've
explained here
gather up all your stuff mariana all the
emails all the copies of everything
and get that to an attorney so you can
sit down and start to shift sift through
this for you
and but here's the lesson folks
and over 30 years of doing this and
you're doing coaching and counseling too
when you do not bring to closure
in writing the end of any kind of an
agreement
and keep records of it it comes back to
bite you in the butt yeah
you can't just drive up with a car and
drop it off at the dealership oh
you can't just move out and go well i
don't pay anymore
you can't um and send an email i mean
you've got to get
a cl you know you've got to get contact
with human beings
get written proof that a conversation
has occurred and the
that there is a release yes uh but
instead you guys just kind of skipped
town
uh trying to do it properly but your
half-butt did it right
and so it came back and bit you uh but
you know okay i settled this with a
collector
uh you know some of you i've heard this
story a thousand times and they promised
me so and so
but you didn't get it in writing if it
ain't in writing it's not real i don't
know how to tell you
and so be an advocate for yourself
meaning call as dave says take notes
dates times of who you spoke with what
was agreed upon
uh that way you've got a clear kind of
communication law and get it in writing
yeah
everything you were not out of this
lease
on from a practical standpoint until you
got a response from them saying
you're out of the lease you've activated
the cancellation clause you're paying
the one month fee to do that
and therefore your fees are this and
until you get that back from somebody
you know you're going to have trouble in
the future that's exactly right and dave
ghosting you is an indication you're
going to have trouble i coached the
client that took a car back to the car
lot left the keys in it
and just left it uh two weeks later the
dealership
it really was and they expected that to
be the end of it it wasn't
no right just the beginning so whatever
you do you've got to get closure on
these things because it comes
back to bite you folks something as
simple as cutting off your cable
something as simple as changing cell
phone providers something is
uh you know simple as settling an old
medical bill
get the piece of paper in writing and
keep a fi a hard copy file on it
email is great but usually a hard copy
you know hit print
throw it in the throw it in the file and
keep it for a while because these people
have screwed up memories